Marton he was saying this before we came
on air that this is absolutely vital and
crucial for Japan how vital is it it's
very important because basically
autonomics the structural part of all
the reform policies are anchored around
TPP opening up the markets liberalizing
markets from agriculture to
pharmaceuticals is very important
domestically even if the negotiations
dragging on a bit if there is a basic
agreement the government can link its
policy to it and push things through
very important well it's not up to them
you know we've got dairy is a bit of a
let's say a stumbling block we've got
other stumbling blocks when it comes to
things like well copyright I suppose you
could put it that way as well it has a
deal really been cobbled together and
we're just waiting for the you know the
lines that teas to be crossed it's
really depends on what you want to see
so far TPP has basically been dead
already quite a few times and every time
we wanted oh they're still keeping on
negotiating and doing things and this
time it looks much better than before
what we would likely want to see is that
we get a basic deal now some final
negotiations through the rest of the
year some signing ceremony early next
year that would be the best-case
scenario it will still stake time until
all the government have come together
and approving things but still we can go
on then moving into that direction
opening up markets and in Japan this is
a very very important case well
absolutely and how does it how long does
it take I mean it's not something which
will happen overnight when it's a deal
is signed how does it resuscitate
economics if indeed AB anomic s-- needs
resuscitation absolutely the government
needs to improve the news flow again
there is very little everybody is
looking again at the Bank of Japan if
the Bank of Japan is doing something
this is so far the only more less
reliable engine of growth so far and of
government action otherwise structural
reforms on the ground are more or less
on hold not much is happening we will
probably see a very similar happen
cabinet line up than we had before so
very little
here this external anchors are therefore
even more important I think is Martin I
lost the last case red was indeed Jean
Darby from Jeffries and he was saying
that well okay the macroeconomic data
looks weak but the micro I couldn't
economic data he said look really good
anything to the facts don't fit the
crime as it were so why is corporate
Japan doing so well on the economy not
hmm
well not even the macro data are that
bad is just with the level of anomic sin
its initial push created and all the
expectations so far the economy is doing
quite well household spending is doing
quite well corporations are planning to
invest they are doing so we have a risk
of situation where implementation is
suffering quite a bit and what we don't
have is the top-line CPI inflation data
the top-line growth data really
following up on what the government has
promised we have inflation increasing we
have increasing prices we have
increasing demand so it's not just micro
macro it's a bit an expectation thing
and it is also what is happening here on
the ground within corporations and
households and that is comparatively
compromising the wages are gonna be
important here and there is wage
inflation but again we do have that
problem of that translating into CPI
growth mmm well so far households are
actually not that happy anymore to see
increasing increasing consumer prices
wages are increasing only very very
slowly overall in particular the
exporters are not doing so well because
the entire environment in Asia has
become so much more tricky domestic
companies are doing very well but now
they're focusing on investment and
profitability very important in Japan we
had very little of that wages will come
later and as long as they are not coming
households don't want to see much higher
prices the Bank of Japan hears that and
is not pushing as hard as before to
boost prices anymore I guess